yeah it's crazy to think about this all
right so talk to me about breaking
points real quick before we get into
kind of bitcoin some of the other stuff
how big is this thing and like talk you
know what it's seven eight months old
now and you guys have taken the world by
storm literally going right at the
throats of fox cnn msnbc etc i see you
smirk so i know you're like yeah that's
exactly what we're doing uh how big is
it and like how have you thought about
the first seven or eight months yeah i
was stunned by it you know i mean look i
was scared at the end of the day like i
was worried about censorship you guys
have had to deal with this as well but i
was like you know what we put in two
years built the audience built the hill
channel from 6k subs to 1.34 million on
the day that we left so look seven
months in we're 700k subscribers on
youtube but the daily numbers are well
above an average cnn prime time
broadcast at least one million whenever
it comes to the actual view or the so
whenever it comes to views and also
within what really matters in news is
something called the key demographic so
this is the bs part like all of these
fox cnn all that they may say three
million it doesn't matter the only thing
that actually matters are the key demo
the 18 to 54 demographic for even tucker
or rachel maddow the highest paid people
the biggest news on broadcasting they
are one-fifth of what breaking points is
actual key demo audiences and that's not
even including the millions of downloads
a month that come on the podcast format
from spotify
to itunes i mean this is what you were
saying this is about the open ecosystem
you don't have to watch me live you can
watch it whenever you want at your
convenience i actually noticed in my
podcast downloads there are some people
who wait until the weekend and then
listen to all three of the episodes not
the way i would consume news but hey
whatever you know it's up to you and i
think that that's the important thing so
look it's bigger than our ever imagined
within seven months we basically blew
out all of our one-year goals within the
first two weeks of launching and making
sure that we were gonna be sustainable
and it's only been uh it's only been up
from there so look i mean people showed
up for us in a big way and made it even
possible and now i'm just you know now
i've got ideas i'm like okay now we've
actually got the ability in the base uh
to upgrade so we upgraded our studio 4k
cameras i literally i was telling you
this from what i understand the
engineers who helped build my studio
told me that we have higher tech than
cnn and msnbc and them
playing field now how is the internet
how pissed is like fox cnn and msnbc do
they even know this is happening or are
they like reaching out to you kind of
back channeling and being like hey this
isn't cool
so it's it's really fast you know what's
the thing it's like first they ignore
you then they copy you then you know
it's like they beat something like that
uh
at first they just wanted to ignore us
they were ignore ignore ignore for the
first two years not just breaking points
whenever we were over at the hill but
here's what started happening and
crystal and i uh would notice that those
people their friends and family members
who aren't into politics at all would
say something like hey do you know those
guys crystal and and i would get texts
and all those things like oh it seems
like you know it seems like you're
really working that type of thing then
what happened is now transitioned to
anger and has been like a total blackout
but i'll be honest like i welcome their
hatred and frankly like i've even said
this the more you guys ruin the country
the better i do like i'm doing better
because you guys are so terrible at your
job so we are in a mutual kind of
antagonism phase uh where you know they
try it's all very inside baseball and it
sounds super petty but because i speak
washington like i know what's going on
like they tried they tried to leave us
off of like the most influential people
and media list
even though they put people on there who
are like junior correspondents or
whatever it's like abc news they try and
black you out of any of the recognitions
and the societies and the accrediting uh
situations but look i don't care numbers
speak for themselves at the end of the
day they know when they go home for
thanksgiving or christmas and they talk
to somebody who is not inside the
beltway at all they're going to be like
hey i watch breaking points that's how i
get my kids dude forget their societies
let's create our own society who wants
to hang out with those losers anyways
yeah
exactly that's my that's my approach in
life